quick tour update gang the state trashy
tour is a cook and we're adding shows
and we're coming to a city near you
bring the squad out and come see us
Austin Texas Texas second show added
there then in April we're hitting New
Haven Connecticut Burlington Vermont new
second show is added in both those
cities what then we're going to Tampa
Florida second show added there Dania
Beach Florida Raleigh North Carolina
Louisville Cleveland get your tickies
now you snooze you lose see you out
there welcome to another exciting
edition of are you garbage the show
where you find out if your favorite
comedians are classy individuals or
absolute trash now here are your hosts
Kevin Ryan and H Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's new favorite podcast this
is are you garbage that little show we
sit down with your favorite comedians
and we find out if they're going to be
classy yeah they're just a big old piece
of trash I'm your host Tate trolley
coming at you on a beautiful day we're
out back here at Toadies and a new
addition baby and let me tell you you
can't tell her not a lot of
inspirational quotes money never sleeps
get your bread up all that kind of stuff
time is money called me fat boy this
morning
I wrote that for her
man she is out there it's crazy yeah got
every mailman and [__] garbage man
truck driver she's bringing them in to
hey come look at the new edition I think
she's [__] throwing a move on them or
stealing their wallets when they get in
here she's a catcher the neighborhood
she's a real estate Tycoon
my co-host is coming at you from across
the table it's a family episode First
Family episode here in the new digs baby
and we can't thank you guys enough we
love you yep and I love him to death
give it up for KJ Kevin James Ryan hey
what's up gang thanks for tuning in as
always please make sure your rate if you
subscribe on iTunes
at YouTube as you know those numbers are
obviously Jesus the greatest gosh darn
website of all time
www.patreon.com are you garbage you go
over there you sign up and you get a
bajillion hours of content patent
pending yeah it's a good time
fudge out game good good time hey how
about this how about a nice quick shout
out to our producer shorty look like by
the way you're about to find out the
magic man makes us all look good works
the ones Works to twos the threes and
the fours now he crosses the t's he dots
the eyes and as I say ladies they get a
little peek at them on that Toby cam
give it up for T-Bone mcgruffins Toby
McMullen everybody hey what's up dude
what up T-Bone oh my dude this video the
first app went live with the cam my mom
started sending decoration ideas we
gotta redo this back wall behind you
she's all over it have you thought about
shiplap
[Music]
which was my original suggestion
and also Patty's suggestion I have all
this shiplap in the garage see a sailor
what the [__] she building boats who's
got that much goddamn ship left
what the [__] only only brought the
neighborhood I got there
I got half the Nina and a whole Santa
Maria in a goddamn garage I don't know
she orders more she's Patty puts things
together Patty doesn't just call a
general contractor and say Hey I want
this done okay she's got the parts she's
got to this she's got that she's got the
nails she's got then they come in and
pieces you do the work I'll get the
stuff yeah she likes to do her Home
Depot runs and watch she's in there
smoking in the plumbing section
I need a new flush valve man God love
her screaming at someone I remember uh
her
she she was a junkyard dog for a while
she really was a nice lady I don't know
what you're talking about
coming off the top rope sure she would
go and Hawk items she'd get a new tail
light or whatever yeah and we'd put it
together God love her we put it together
in the freezing cold in the driveway
sure with the garage light on I don't
know where my dad was yeah it's [__]
I don't know but I'd be with him he was
trying to get away from you [__]
inside knocking back a tuner Oogie man
we did for a long time and we we've
talked about it before but uh used tires
we'd go somewhere big Market times were
tough and we had a big dot a big jacked
up souped up Dodge Ram and the tires on
that thing would go all the time it was
I popped one on the [__] Ben Franklin
Bridge wait hold on Dodge Ram truck yeah
it's your pops yes is the work truck the
piece wasn't rolling around no no no no
no no no no no no no no no she was in
the she was in the [__] bravado at
that point pulled into two lanes at the
Wawa uh no this thing was heavy bike big
those those Dodge Ram trucks man jacked
up we do not want to get hit by one of
those puppies I was driving it and I'll
take a Tacoma the tires were all wonky I
had to drive down to go fix like a
[__] supermarket in South Jersey and
I was crossing back over the Ben
Franklin Bridge I remember calling my
Pickle Barrel broke
you in a jack truck you probably look
like a nun driving oh man I had I was
cranking heavy heaters at the time I'm
sure I think Windows barely do you ever
get in a work truck you go this is a
work truck it's coffee Bernie's and old
paperwork real good maps in there in the
wintertime man put on a little [__]
AM radio oh the heat never worked or it
worked too well that was the problem a
lot of times you had to keep the heat
cooking so the engine didn't overheat
yeah I like that though when it's a
little bit cold in the work truck and
you find warmth in like your jacket and
your stocking hat I don't know a little
I was making a lot of snack stops at the
time there was this Luke oil on Street
Road hot the soft pretzels the [__]
tall boy on our Palmers and a pack of
goldfish I'd park over by the vacuum
machine and go to damn
some guy tried to put air in his tires I
haven't done it in a minute [__]
how was my lunch dinner everything you
do like your gummy bees I'll tell you
that my gummy bees your gummy bear no I
said goldfish I do like a nice gummy
bear yeah he had about six packs of them
so far in the last 24 hours yeah
um but we would have to go get used
tires at this place I don't even know we
found it like the classifieds are
dangerous
yeah it was down off 95. no not that
using used tires Oh I thought the place
the place was a little seedy if you get
that's one thing my dad didn't didn't go
for never buy you you're getting that
fresh tires yeah but the tires for this
truck were like [__] you know like
300 a clip uh you're getting used tires
yeah we were jammed up we were
financially a couple of baldies on there
let's go
they would put them on you'd get about
200 miles and then it feels like the car
got hit with a rocket launcher dude
these things this thing exploded on the
Ben Franklin Bridge I thought we were
taking enemy fire five two [__]
sparks flying the whole nine yards
Second Generation Kill over there uh-huh
it was uh yeah but the used tires were
so big and looking back that is very
dangerous
because I don't think they were like hey
this is our standard they were going
just [__] standards what I mean blue
says yes yeah that's all it is I think
there's got there has to be some sort of
rule of Regulation to selling used this
place didn't have a sign or nothing
those things go up real easy dude you
had to drive by a [__] it was like a
jail I don't know where it was it was
like a mini jail and there was I don't
know it was like a holding tank or what
off 95 barbed wire what are they killer
whales I'd known there was chicks there
and it was like chicks in the prison
yeah all right and they were running
games they were playing ball in the yard
[__] brother Duncan in jail it was a
Bassy scene you know the other side of
the fence eating your Tasty Cake what's
up ladies you like soft pretzels
um tractor trailers do that [__] a lot
which is nerve-wracking yeah I heard
they're gonna retread they retread it
with like glue or that's why you [__]
you see them on the highway that
shouldn't be legal I heard that the
first time like no [__] white but
that crazy came to be the truth I had to
blowout one time on a Long Island
Expressway and a conversion van
when I was uh things were going well
like a year when I was in the Virgin van
it was like a work work van isn't that
what a conversion conversion van is when
you put the captain's chairs when you
hook it up yeah the work van converted
into okay yeah this is a regular
[__] we borrowed our my dad's buddy
Sam's
conversion van to drive to [__]
Montreal one time man couldn't tell me
[__]
we got lost for about nine hours dude I
had a major blowout on uh on 90 on the
Long Island Expressway one time had a
technician with me and dude like you
said it was it was it was my crowning
achievement of manhood sure grabbed the
wheel
brought it over to the side jumped out
changed the tire on 495 got back in Yeah
clean sailing I remember one time in
that scary in that same truck uh we got
a [__] I think my brother might have
been driving or I was driving turn
Pennsylvania Turnpike boom shoot tires
the tires would go on this thing all the
time like five eight five or six a year
um and two treated time oh man jammed up
so we had to go to a Pep Boys because
the jack
in the car it was like an aftermarket
jacket like suspension raise the was
raised aftermarket we bought it used
okay so the jack on the car wasn't tall
enough to jack up the truck what did I
have 22s on it or just got a couple of
spinners had Lamborghini doors on us
like a goddamn 57 video
I'm [__] I'm [__] crippled I'm
[__] ghost riding this thing down the
Pepsi Turnpike
uh you in the office baby
look I didn't know you'd get wet what
the [__]
car turns purple inside
ah
Pep Boys
so we had to go to Pep Boys to buy a
jack
like a race car jet you know what I mean
like the the big stick want like to jack
it up okay the little dinky one couldn't
get the car up I mean like an actual
like like a Snap-On [__] just ain't
cheap no that's why we [__] fixed the
tire back to back up and returned it
right after everything don't work
[__] she's like I remember my dad
was like I'll give you 50 bucks if you
can return this thing and I walked in
ahead and I was like Hey listen it was
broken whatever I just gave it a run
around that's when I knew we were real
dirtbags my dad was going to give me a
cut of the return if we were able to
return the expensive equipment
this is man I'm out 300 right now I'll
give you 50 if you get me 250 back
yeah ah Jesus uh I have another update
on uh
the cleaning lady debacle okay remember
I said she posted a story how can we
forget I got a goddamn hard post last
week
she posted on a goddamn grid this broad
you're gonna need to ship that you tried
to make me a collaborator
and partner with this guy's at
dirtbag.com going after your fan base
yeah I was like what the [__] lady why
don't you tell her to stop I don't know
what it is Broad I don't know her the
wife's In Cahoots you having her back
yeah she was supposed to come yesterday
but [__] left me high and dry yeah
she's [__] influencer I know I'm too
busy getting rich off my grind
[Laughter]
[__] paid sponsorship yeah but it was
nice to see she did post other ones that
were significantly worse than our
bathtub and like a bathtub whatever I'm
not not making a bathtub can get away
from you you know what I mean uh but
like people were posting their kitchens
it looked like the [__] spaghetti
bomb went off dude there was [__] it was
dirty you're all catching a microwave
that was always my job as a kid to scrub
the toilet Patty would you ruined it
most of the time probably Patty would
put me on the bathroom I was pretty good
too we had uh we had a cleaning lady
that would be a comment guy like a good
Comet looking back I don't know how to
[__] it's still like I think my mom pays
her 50 bucks every two weeks because
dude that whole giant whole house man
Jesus she comes [__] Scrubbing
Bubbles dude all over she would catch me
[__] I'd be hung over sleeping on the
couch [__] half a woody going she
walk in it [__] it was always 10 a.m
on Fridays I'd be [__] out dude she'd
pop in sometimes early eight o'clock
sometimes you bring a partner with her
I'm like oh he's doing I'm running
upstairs with a [__] morning wood
with a [__] throw pillow in front I
gotta get to the gym a little bit
they're sick there's you know tissues
laying around oh God you spank it I was
sick you spank it down here not in the
living room
over there now
back in the day sure in the living room
you ain't never anything I mean what are
we doing here gonna sit there the man
man of your a man of your level of trash
is gonna you're gonna sit there and tell
me
I may be a late night something like
that yeah I'm not talking lunchtime I'm
not [__] I'm not you're not pulling
nooners dude still Smelling Coffee
are you nuts
catch Angel hard on Showtime hey I
didn't have cable upstairs
sometimes Steve Wilkos pops off yeah you
know what I mean a titty flops out of
the fight sometimes that Judge Judy
would do it for me
like a woman of authority
Patty does the lady I think like once
now
hey I told you it was the 70s you follow
these are freaks here we are
um bad family of Watchers
you're going to want to see this
the four chairs lined up why do all of
your closets have peoples
Pekin
um she gets a lady every I don't know
like three like once a month but she
cleans before she gets yeah that was
always a thing and then clean your room
and the niece is coming and then leaves
the house as if they were bombing it for
like centipedes sure hey yeah you can't
be in the house when she's here whenever
they get out I remember getting yelled
out for walking on the floor afterwards
I'm like well what are we gonna We live
outside now I can't go in a kitchen yeah
this is ridiculous crazy
I feel like a nice clean floor though
yeah of course what are we [__] yeah
we don't like a nice clean floor I
remember when Patty used to run the
cleaner run the carp run the vacuum
cleaner like a Wednesday night right
before my programs came on get down on
the carpet [__] man Colleen living
it was all right little things in life
huh big guy yeah see the lines in the
carpet Hachi Machi yeah like a Dominican
barber
clean living we got a low fade in the
living room uh all right this is a gosh
thing gosh darn Family episode as you
know you know answer your garbage
questions and we defer to patreon for
that when you sign up for patreon we
will answer your garbage question on the
air
uh this one's from Toody's plug do two
used dryer sheets equal one fresh dryer
sheet yes of course 100 yes spin jammed
up with that you start I even dig
through the trash can when you got a
full box of them how many you use in per
load I uh I'm three or four nah that's
data leaves too much residue on it I
like well you know that nah that's
that's apparently what we've been doing
is we have those bad for you all that
shit's bad for you the dishwashing soap
the [__] laundry detergent speaking
of dishwashing so we were using you know
something nicer like more healthy or not
as toxic but still that's seven
generations that might have been that
yeah no that was all right good luck
getting eggplant parm off the plate no
that was doing the job that was fine I
can see that I go okay this stuff is
working then we cut it over to [__]
she just went one step [__] all
plant-based [__] just water and rose
petals oh my god dude I was pulling out
there was more food on the [__] I was
like what is this washing your dishes
like a Roman yeah watching a [__]
Creekside down there [__] Stone
washing these goddamn plates I'll tell
you what though you really see how bad
because we got the dishwasher and we
have those little pouches you can see
why kids want to eat them too they're
[__] look they do have a little
tension into him but man that just looks
that's a billion different chemicals
sure yeah yeah you know of course but
the dryer sheets I like that shine we've
recently been using and I I [__] love
them I was anti I'm anti-anything
[__] I think I know what you're about
to say the whole balls okay yeah yeah
you get like they're like the size like
a softball they come in like packs of
six and you reuse them and the natural
oils from the wool lamb skin wool hair
what is wool cheap sheep sheep uh the
ostrich feathers they uh they they put
something on it you put oil in it you
can I think for smell we just go we just
roll dog I think I've never put anything
in them walking around smelling like
mutton
what are you talking about got a couple
of chops yeah I'm sure they put your the
broad puts a little lavender drops in
there or something I don't think the
Kippy really smells like winter socks
kids about to go I smell like a ski
lodge in here I gotta hankering for some
stew
get out of here with that no they're
great and you I do I have realized that
after I do use uh well now I do a
drop-off service for sure uh they do it
and I don't think they're using the wool
balls I'm getting [__] industrial
strange [__] but you feel it on the
clothes like too much it gets in your
hands because what dryer sheets do is
they just coat your clothes in a
chemical sure that's what it does fabric
softener yeah and they just coat it in
the American way uh and I I now that I
have had not had it it's it's tough to
go back to
smells good you know what the birds
using which I thought you were going to
say as a little BBS Little pellets I
don't know where they go the soap stuff
now they're like um fabric softener I
assume it's fabric softener I don't know
if it goes in a dryer or in the washing
machine goes in the washer does it I
believe so yeah it's just like sober the
old school sheets bounce get a fresh
boxing in
yeah that's what we use or while for a
long time I guess when money was looking
back it was American Standard it was the
Super Fresh brand you'd have to go
through about 45 of those for a pair of
jeans in the morning oh Pat weed that
was never had no there was never a
fabric softener or uh dryer sheets in
the house until post 911 at the Foley
household
I don't know I think I didn't know
Halliburton early
I'm not gonna take my goddamn dryer
sheets from me I'll tell you that much
oh Patriot Act
[Laughter]
that's what they have my text messages
you ain't taking my Fabrics off that's
when they started doing good addition
started popping up after the laundry
room got redone and the dryer sheet
showed up sure back in the day I went to
school smelling like burnt wood okay
let's talk about stamps.com steve.com
steams.com stamps.com stamps.com I'll
say it one more time gang who has time
to waste in the post office get yourself
on stamps.com you can do this all from
your home or your home office yeah you
get rates so you can that you can't find
anywhere else like 84 off ups and USPS
84 you're losing money if you don't send
stuff about to start sending you stuff
there you go they'll send you a free
scale and everything you need to get
started it's fantastic I've been using
it for years it's what we sent out all
the cards with uh it's easy peasy to
send you everything you need the stamps
uh the printer prints it out you lick it
you stick it you get it on there out the
door uh you can trust stamps.com for
over 20 25 years they've helped over 1
million businesses set your businesses
up for Success when you get started with
stamps.com today sign up with promo code
garbage for a special offer that
includes four-week trial plus free
postage and a free digital scale no
long-term commitments or contracts
required just go to stamps.com Click the
microphone at the top of the home page
enter our code garbage
g-a-r-b-a-g-e one more time enter code
garbage at top of the homepage Click the
microphone it's easy peasy out the door
okay let's talk about Lucy Lucy Lucy
let's talk about Lucy nicotine pouches
now I've been running my mouth talking
about the other brand but I'm telling
you right now Lucy is the way to go
uh-huh all right you don't want to be
getting your [__] at a gas station like
some kind of dirt bag through Lucy
delivered right to your door absolutely
fantastic flavors plus you get to
monitor how much you want top shelf I'm
telling you right now gang do it yeah
you choose the mint the mango I like the
espresso and apple cider
not together
they're two different flavors yes give
Lucy a shot they're fantastic what are
you waiting for to select your strength
and nicotine I like the I like the heavy
boy Banger I like that little guy take
the edge off uh you get ready for
experience like no other uh visit
lucy.com
and use code garbage to get 20 off your
first order shipping is always free
that's Lucy dot c-o-l-u-c-y dot Co promo
code garbage to receive 20 off and
always free shipping Lucy products are
for adults of legal age only of course
and every order is age verified warning
this product contains nicotine
nicotine's addictive chemical and back
to the show back to the show it's more
of a static thing for me I did dude yeah
the the cold from the cult from the yeah
the coal stove from the barbecue from
the morning barbecue
[Laughter]
who wants brisket and eggs gang that
sounds good
um yeah and plus the heaters
the heaters in the house in the winter I
just smelled like heaters probably my
whole life and didn't know I remember I
would get in a car with a parent and I
they I would just have to smell like
heaters yeah no idea step dad cranking
them in the crib until
the [__] probably early till 9 11
probably uh she when she kicked it and
then he would go outside to have them
my dad or in the car or any car sure
smoking section all his kids sure I had
to just think like more Reds and Winston
yeah you could really tell I had my
wrestling bag and I would get my jeans
and my shirt whatever I was wearing that
day put them in my bag get picked up in
the morning to go to wrestling practice
do wrestling practice and then take a
shower and get ready to go up to the
class I'd [__] open up that bag
everybody around me like God damn Foley
it would just smell like old heaters oh
stinking ain't nothing worse but it
wasn't too bad because everybody around
me was all in the same boat we were big
either they smelled like heaters or my
one buddy uh Steve smelled like a proper
uh fireplace that was that was their
main source of heat in the winter was it
was an actual Fire or the 1400s like
Jesus Christ who are you Leanne Chrysler
[__] rolling around like a goddamn
coal miner yeah I definitely told you
that but yeah you have his face is all
black
like a chimney sweep
um
dryer sheets also came very important in
about Junior High when the heater
started let's go you leave the house
that and the doobies you grab about two
or three [__] dryer sheets cologne to
take out well cologne was a dead
giveaway if you put if you came home at
10 o'clock or got in the car your mom
picking you up you smelly cologne
something's up she she knows you've been
[__] dipping and dabbling you know
what I mean but if you smell like
bouncer [__] smells like [__] when
you left the house yeah you dirt bagging
him showered three days I come and smell
like a French horn
you're up to something
um so dryer sheets would neutralize it
it wouldn't it would mask it rather than
it would neutralize it rather than try
to cover it that they were big that and
uh all right you rub them on your hands
rub them on your clothes but you can
never go too much I'll tell you right
now I'll buy any product that has the
Febreze logo on it oh yeah I just bought
something buy a house with that yeah
with the Febreze logo
the original Febreze was a game changer
it was like real liquid it sucked it was
like spray liquid it didn't smell good
oh I loved it you did
we didn't use it in that house
I don't know why the way they changed
the game which they're really double
dipping now but the way they change the
game is that it was wasn't and I
remember before that it was the Glade
[__] which was great
that was all right all right you got
into somebody's house who was doing well
they had that in the bathroom no I mean
the the GLA oh yeah okay that's what I'm
saying you go to take a poop oh the
plug-in sucked they lasted for about two
weeks that technology has gotten pretty
good then the dog started licking them
uh I used to wear them as pagers when I
was playing drug dealers because I had
the little clip
well no you are the one in the car you
would put it on like the visor in the
car I'd [__] I acted like it was a
beeper oh hold on they called let me
call me Tropical Breeze what's up
Danny's
steak these [__] won't stop blowing
me up for a while Patty had the things
where you the gel tones and they just
disappear that don't make no sense they
were big in college man
because we would have I used to be
scared to go to the bathroom at night
with those things uh for that thing to
come alive the cone it would just eat
away and then you started seeing those
at the dollar store there was a time
where I did a lot of shopping at the
dollar store when I moved out on my own
or in college it was like let's go here
spend 20 bucks and have cleaning
products for the month it was nice yeah
feels good
um I was at my boy's house and he was
like you hungry I was like yeah he's
like I'll make some broccoli it's mostly
stems it's from the dollar store
yikes that's what a new train says
though mostly stems holy [__] it's bad
weed dude stems and rubber bands
it's just red rubber bands but back to
Febreze before that it was air freshener
febreze's uh a marketing thing was that
you spray the fabric it didn't mask it
it eliminated it everything messed but
it was right it was actually spread you
sprayed the couch with it yeah you
didn't spray it in the air you sprayed
it yeah that goddamn dog on the couch
all the time in a commercial [__]
mother no good that [__] deal with
that dog Jesus sidewalks where you live
lady are you kidding me here
um but their Original Scent was not
great I loved it he was like perfect
amount of chemically I was a big fan
um
but we well we had the air freshener in
the we were never good at keeping stuff
in stock no you know what I mean like
you would go over someone's house and
they always had everything we were like
oh we had two cans and then after six
months that just went away or what two
mile a month or whatever that was it and
then it was like we'd go ten more years
without more my mom's I just bought them
what are you and I'm like the same stuff
I've been huffing them for weeks lady
the same stick them on the side of the
[__] stickems The Stick of the thing
you're playing with your pocket oh you
made my beeper the little round one so
you'd open up oh Crank That open is that
what you're talking about no you're
talking about the Glade plug-in no there
was one you would get for your car it
was like a Glade plug-in but I had a
hook on it you would put it on your
visor
AKA kippy's pager I did have a pager no
one ever paged me
not once I was so upset no matter how
stocked your cleaning supplies were
everyone always had like a half bottle
of that like Pine cleaner in the orange
you know what I'm saying oh yeah yeah
I'm sorry you're talking about Pine salt
not Pine salt it's like wood cleaner
it's in like everybody's house
yeah yeah we only need that one tube of
that or uh these oil soap Yes Murphy man
breaking out the Murphys Jesus you felt
like a bar Maiden holy [__] that stuff
smells great though
there was this bowl on that kitchen
floor there was always a lot of paint
thinner around too
I thought they were cooking meth or
something or what they were dirt what
they were doing but there was all I knew
about paint thinner at a very young age
it was getting tossed around a lot yeah
Don't Go Near that yeah I'll get some
paint thinner he's got a [__] heater
on [__] doing the paint thinner we
always had uh I guess it was like I
think it was for wood it wasn't PL it
was it was the one step above pledge
that like when you had a
scratched a little bit yes you got that
[__] on your hands forget about it
[__] a month that was coming off I
don't remember that we had a bottle of
that and a [__] rag that looked like
a pen had blown up on top of it for
about 25 years yeah we were always big
on Rags because like the construction
company so my dad always shop ragging
had them in the trunk had them had them
in the Jeep had them in the garage had
them at work they were [__]
everywhere if you had a choice you can
only have paper towels or a rag paper
towels all day long paper towels are one
of the greatest inventions of all time
but what if you kept a cycle going where
you had fresh Rags all the time I'd go
rag nah they're not a t-shirts got to be
old older now they're not a they're not
as absorbent than paper towels paper
towels are the one of the most absorbent
things
they you can't get a good real dry you
bring around we spill right here you
bring a rag out it's not gonna [__]
complete there's still gonna be a
[__] water paper towel soaks it up
who got the Kippy brawny Bounty huh
somebody's sliding I don't know whoa
[Laughter]
I love brownie price Mr Clean I got an
ax
there it is it's fantastic hey man
better cows are great then use it for
everything uses a plate use a toilet
paper whatever you want let me tell you
something all right easy does it there I
didn't want to get into it and we're not
going to we know how you feel about
toilet paper in the bathroom that's
that's enough paper towels should just
be toilet paper this isn't your poopy
hour all right uh grip all right let's
see this one's from Stephen climb with
those things [__] free solo ten
dollar homie is it garbage your parents
gave you wine coolers for your ADHD in
the 80s holy [__]
hey what do you [__] hey we gotta
ants in your pants to take the edge off
will you
I can't focus mom well now you can't
drive
holy [__] let your hair down a little
bit have some fun
that's crazy
shout out to Seagram's wine coolers
though first booze that was ever bought
for me I was way too young for the
person to be buying it for me I was a
Bartles and James man you guys probably
don't remember them do you no I didn't
grow up bottles and James 40s
Bartles and James
they were they were the original wine
coolers you know you pick them up with
your pocket there
you know the doctor prescribed it
takes three weeks to deliver
um no they they they were like the
original wine cooler and they used to do
the commercial it was it was two old
guys on a porch that'd be that'd be push
just checking out yeah Tyler would be
pushing these things bottles and James
wine coolers okay I think they were a
wine maker before that sure and then
when the 80s hit you know he got
Diversified a little bit Yeah hair metal
baby you gotta [__] you gotta go
after the demo nobody wants to be
drinking Merlot with a [__] had a
poison concert
you know what
he gotta Spruce it up a bit [__]
light your hair down baby let's go round
and round
can't change the line of yak yak with a
Cabernet you know what I mean maybe
carrying those goddamn glasses around
oh [__] those things were all right but
that's illegal my God you're giving a
kid booze
yeah it didn't matter back then I used
to get them no I'm saying the the
question that was the 80s that wasn't
illegal in the 80s probably not gonna
fight it was frowned upon for sure it
wasn't illegal I mean in the 90s
yeah it was probably if I was 86 I was
four five seven yeah I used to get
[__] Jack Daniels on on the on the
gums for a toothache yeah of course I
loved it I had a lot of two things oh
yeah I still do
didn't do anything still get toothpicks
every night it didn't do anything
it gave me alcoholism
that's big whiskey got the got their
clothes in me quick
something
I don't know gave me a horrible drinking
problem I don't know if they did that to
put you to sleep it was to numb it it
was like local numbing yeah it didn't
work it worked for me
two more
hey Barky
run it back for me my friends please
can I backed these up please do the next
200 rocks will you
oh yeah yeah I was that was big I loved
it uh and I remember I was so young that
I thought it instead of Tennessee
whiskey I thought it said Japanese
whiskey
International if I remember asking my
mom can I have some more Japanese
whiskey and she's like what the [__] are
you talking about this is America
Goddamn [__] you've been hanging out
that stuff
that's out of the karaoke bars again
hasn't even hit the market yet
I remember when Japanese whiskey really
broke through that was a big thing
probably 10 years ago yeah yeah I
remember that good stuff
um all right let's see here uh this
one's from Brian blue balls this just
says I gotta know what's the high score
on the Big Buck Hunter there uh I want
to say it's either Luke or you right
as a whole I think it's Luke Luke as of
now uh-huh is Top Dog on the Buck Hunter
Machine yeah uh yeah I will give it a
caveat uh I will say I'm probably the
best player
on the team Jesus uh this is what I've
only played more with me huh yeah it's
tough yeah it's very tough because I'll
tell you what Cube all the scores says
different I've only played the hot
shooter I only played one full game Luke
I mean we went on a road Luke sat here
for like 10 hours and played
he's like dude I played a lot of big
buck and I'm like you're supposed to be
working [__] you can't tell your
boss you're slacking off playing video
games
but yeah that'll be uh that would be an
expensive sandwiches that'll be an
ongoing thing I will reign supreme my
goal is to have every top scorer to be
the hunter hero I just want to say this
let's zoom in on me
from what I remember it really is
[__] pound for pound
a great [__] video game Big Buck
Hunter dude it's it's [__] it's the
best board game it's it's enough the gun
works great the [__] way they keep it
moving I tell you when those deer
[__] slump over and I love deer I've
never [__] hurt a deer in my life but
this you're fitting in the herd
God otherwise we're gonna be getting hit
by cars and running your house and [__]
like that I was getting a little myself
thinking about like guys who show up
with their own pool cue or their own
bowling ball walking into a bar with
your own Buck under guns loading in
I just need a cable
you guys got an XLR cable on you uh it's
the red yellow and white one I I fell in
love with it in my early 20s uh at the
at the bar called The Pub we would hang
out at uh never really played it they
didn't have enough money to play it all
because all of our money at the time
went to booze shout out to Vinnie with
the skin he was flush at the time and he
would [__] he'd put fives in so the
four of us could do a trek you know he
was a skinny on Big Buck Hunter great
um and uh
we had dreams of buying one we've pulled
our money together to get one and now we
finally have one which is [__] sweet
but it's the best game because you all
you're only checked in for about 20
seconds right you're shooting for about
20 seconds around then you got about a
minute minute and a half two to two and
a half minutes that's what I'm saying it
keeps you can go like I'm gonna run the
bathroom I'm gonna go catch a stinger
I'm gonna go [__] order another round
that's four people too that's a good
time I know you're so [__] it's a
great cycle not a lot of like you're
just [__] checked in every Tuesday
yeah I love I never really [__] with
it it's the best baby ever really [__]
with it uh all right let's see here uh
this one's from Garbage Pail poppy
14.50 Canadian homie junkie here haven't
had one red is it garbage to put basic
amenities on a Christmas list as a kids
growing up I would ask for a basic cable
package for Christmas one year and my
parents told me Santa's elves don't do
installations
that's a Union Gig yells can't do it
can't be doing side work these Jesus
Christ damn that's tough man but as a
kid who wanted we had cable downstairs
but I want a cable upstairs so [__]
bad and it was like I'll give I'll pay
for the installation but we just never
[__] got it you didn't have that
money but like after like my my goal was
always like hey after a birthday if I
have like 150 bucks I'll give that to my
mom to cover the installation she didn't
want it and that wasn't the point you
know that now yeah but she's brought
your fat ass up there [__] watching
TV all day yeah well now I'm downstairs
jerking off in the living room what do
you want
laughs
it's the way you want it lady all right
you made the rules tuts
can't be doing this in the privacy of my
own Boudoir what do you want from it man
you deprived me of hot chicks in my room
yeah it's a tough look man okay let's
talk about freeze pipe freeze that pipe
baby Freeze the pipe and let me tell you
something let's talk about not burning
your lungs every time time you try to
take a hit yeah looking like a bubble
gumer at the party she ain't gonna bang
it in when you're coughing up like an
idiot do yourself a favor get freeze
bite cools down the smoke hundreds of
degrees you have to take big fatty Daddy
it's like a big boy yeah the pipe comes
with a detachable chamber pop that in
your freezer for an hour and get ready
for the high that's cool and refreshing
they sent over a couple of Contraptions
over to tutti's over here that in the
freezer right now icing down like a
bottle of [__] hoodie uses it last time
I saw her she was on the moon if you
catch my drift I thought the place was
on fire a freeze pipe cools down the
Smoke by 100 degrees for a more
enjoyable inhale whether you hit a pipe
a bubble or bong or a dab they got it
all baby got you covered up go to
thefreeze pipe.com and press in code
garbage to save 10 off your first order
get your bong your bike or your bubbler
today that's the freezepipe.com
freezepipe.com and pressing the code
garbage
g-a-r-b-a-g-e to save ten percent if you
can smoke from it freeze pipe as you're
back they make it now back to the show
back to the show uh all right let's see
here this one's from Danny Hollywood 20
home he never had one red is a garbage
or brush your teeth in the bathtub
yeah I was anti-shower but at least
there's a drain you can't be spitting
and then sitting in your own [__]
bull yeah that don't even look good in
the sink sometimes let alone you're
[__] floating around in it man you
ever not realize where that's going and
it dries up and after a couple days
you're looking at you're like what the
[__] it's getting [__] spackle off
the floor yeah you got to get a chisel
out this goes everywhere
whip shout out to throw in mud that's
when you're when you're we got some
[__] joint compound in your [__]
hanging drywall shout out to cousin
Mikey for putting the drywall up
shout out to him he texted me he's like
hey man the place looks great I was like
I forgot you that you worked on it two
weeks ago it feels like a million years
ago
it does dude that seems like a hundred
that seems like a lifetime ago wow it
was up here throwing mud uh man's man
that Mikey
shout out to him uh this one's from
Sideshow Bob will you drink an open flat
day old beer I guess it was left out
I can't do it not a beer but I will
drink uh a cold flat soda out of the
fridge especially in the middle of the
night love it [__] straight syrup
right down and I was telling one of you
[__] this the other day
if it's what the [__]
[Laughter]
if it's the right time of the year let
me guess you like soda
[__] and I'm the [__] hey [__]
to write Tuesday I love soda any day of
the week this guy's good
um no if it's the right time of the year
yeah back pedal out of this one somehow
no it's not soda well it could be a soda
soda
all righty you wanted soda and soda if
it's the right time of the year and I
leave an iced coffee or a coffee or a
water in the car sure I'm crushing that
up to a week
black coffee up to a week now come on
you're better than five business days
what if Monday's a holiday
uh all right this one's from Susie Q are
you garbage if you eat microwave popcorn
out of the ice bucket in your hotel room
oh that's a good idea no it's not that's
dirty put the plastic in there I assume
I guess so maybe I've never done that
can't eat it out of the bag why know
that because all that shit's on the
sides
it comes with that's the bowl that's the
container is the bag I got to put it in
a bucket and flip it around a little bit
and let the essence perm you know you
can do that in the bag nah it's not the
same
I'm a bowl man I don't know what to tell
you I understand but an ice bucket at a
hotel at a [__] insane
but you're reading it off the ironing
board who gives a [__] I can't do it oh
I don't
the ice bucket I rarely ever use the ice
bucket now that I think about it what do
you want your honeymoon yeah you know I
use it to fill if I'm filling up I used
to put you know if I'm with the boys or
something put it put it in the bag put
it in the bag you don't get enough in
that bucket that bucket stinking you put
it in the bag and you do a couple of
trips and you [__] put the beers in
the sink yeah like a goddamn gentleman
that's what you do put a little water in
there
blow water [__] make it nice and cool
uh wash your hands in the tub all right
this one's from Jack Campbell where do
we land on keeping a stick of morning
deodorant in the freezer for a
refreshing chill to wake you up in the
morning whoa that's a [__] game
changer that might be all right that's
all right I've heard about gummy bears
in the freezer
because they're really good when you put
them in the freezer oh my fat guy for
him yeah
God damn it laughs
my fed it sub fed it
that's awesome
I like that
put it in the freezer that might be a
[__] that might be one of those moves
I never heard of that I never tried it I
don't think it's true that's not trashy
to me I don't see how that's trashy
a lot of the birds put [__] in the
freezer now they're like they're Rollies
the Jade all that Jade roller is that
what it is a jade roller yeah we gotta
do that feels all right yeah it's all
right makes my belly button tingle
scrapes out your lymph nodes or
something like that yeah it flushes them
out yeah we got all that [__]
um I remember Patty used to rock that
like the original [__] ice mask yeah
yikes
that was for hangovers [__] ice down
the skull
I remember she had that thing in the
freezer who used to play [__] Lone
Ranger with it but yeah I played Ninja
Turtles that was Donatello yeah yeah
kicking a hole in the door get off my
mask uh yeah we have one I don't think I
ever saw Denise wear it though
um yeah she's supposed to wear it at
night yeah man I do see my mom at night
no I mean like when she's going to bed
oh we did share a bed for a while you do
a little creeping
uh uh all right do you ever sleep in
there with her when you were a kid yeah
yeah I definitely did way too long me
too we're being honest here
she had the good TV yeah I'd come back
from college you know
you're stuck in the dresser
[Laughter]
mommy
my dad traveled a lot my dad was gone
for I would be too
but
if I can have you with the house just
sitting in the car in the parking lot
now from you and three pounds to [__]
shiplap I'd be out
I would say from like uh maybe third
grade
um until like seventh grade seventh is
late he was gone during the week a lot
he was gone and Patty made it nice man
the [__] room would be nice we get in
bed around nine o'clock throw on [__]
Moonlighting throw a move on her
yeah dude I like I I never wanted to be
alone as a kid uh yeah I think I
couldn't handle it sure I was probably
the same yes I was doing my business
it's probably the same
uh but my obvious her parents got
divorced and then so she got that big
bed up there yeah so she was she was
there by herself and the thing was uh
the big uh impetus of it was I was
wanted to watch again goes back to the
TVs my sisters there's only two working
TVs in the house yeah dude we have me my
brother my sister and my mom my sister's
watching like [__] 90210
and [__] Melrose Place or something
meanwhile I'm trying to watch Monday
Night Raw or [__] you know Nitro or
something and until the TV was upstairs
and sometimes I'd pay us out you know
what I mean get excited from [__] all
this Stone Cold Steve Austin the
stunners that were going around I'd get
a headache and pass out
catch yourself in a suplex
yeah it was all right man it was all
right I used to like when I was a little
kid truth be told my favorite thing was
to sleep in the middle of them
I pushed that I remember my dad like no
you're not doing it that's it I remember
him putting the kai Bush on that okay
shining his little Willy wet probably
yeah yeah you're in there gumming up the
works
hey five I told you I like showed it
yes Henry we know you like showed us it
was in the car I'll drink it for a week
I'll drink it even yeah I'll drink you
guys doing this summer under a rockstar
box with a fox I remember them trying to
break me of that and man I really put up
a [__] fight I just [__] would
wait
I'd sit there in the [__] shadows and
wait till I fell asleep in the [__]
climbing jokes on you [__] suspend
down from the ceiling night night big
guy oh man it was so cozy in there you
ever do that
really oh man it was all right snuggled
in between Patty and Tucker date yeah
um yeah it was uh I'm trying to think of
what age probably third grade fourth
grade Maybe
this is last summer
yeah
um all right let's see here this is from
Kippy long stockings new ten dollar
homie shout out to you by the way the
most popular homie uh never have one red
is it garbage to tell people that we
have a beach house or we have a
houseboat when in reality it's a family
member's place where you keep that
knowledge to yourself
I 100 said we had a shorehouse when it
was my aunt shore house for about 15
years really the sea aisle all those
times I've been to Sia growing up in Sea
Isle my mom didn't get they got a condo
in Wildwood my cousin Kelly is a shore
house I mean I got your house no I could
stay whenever I want
we just can't sleep with me
I mean you give someone the the garage
code you might as well be passing the
deed over to him that's true that's true
yeah you got that remember that code to
the garage
man couldn't tell you [__] yeah my buddy
uh uh Phil X shout out to Phil X uh he
had early 20s graduated college
everybody gets their first job or
whatever living in the city
uh just big [__] part like just you
know drinking like a [__] [__]
smoking a lot of Bernies I was when
Fireball just hit too I think it was a
[__]
say crazy time for everybody Fireball
and Jaeger were heavy bike at the time I
miss Jaeger I'll be honest with you
I too long ago
Shooters and it was like are they bad
what it's not like cheap liquor right
Jagermeister is good stuff yeah I think
it's it's an acquired if you don't like
it you don't like it I love it yeah I I
think but it's not like I was like I
didn't I didn't I wouldn't do shots of
whiskey for a long time no I'm a whiskey
man it's not like a Japanese whisk it's
not like Aftershock it's like that's a
that's I like Aftershock I like Fireball
anything with a flavor I'm in Fireballs
teetering on it but Aftershock is like
garbage like that you know got
fireball's trash too Jagermeister is
like an authentic European liquor
correct German yeah it's German it's got
56 herbs and spices it's like the KFC
liquor yeah they're big on their herbs
and spices over there so that is legit
you could as an adult theoretically have
a shot of Jaeger sure I would say it's
probably I think it's just been adopted
by like you realize that I'm prepping
you both for right shots of Jaeger I'll
[__] do one right now I don't care
heading down to Tejas you know what's a
nice piece of marketing that [__]
Jagermeister soft serve machine they got
that's [__] Jaeger hit me up I'm pulling
on the [__] bar let me wear my big in
Jaeger
put a little Jagger behind the ears
let's go someone hit up Jaeger you know
who schultzy knows Jaeger really yeah
that's who flies him all over the
[__] world no kidding that's all
presented by Jaeger
whoa God damn it Chelsea doing all right
guys Schultz wins again shout out to him
come on let me get some beer money hit
me up at least free booze something
[__] jamming me we're gonna wind up
with an Aftershock slushy machine yes I
would be that bad
come on man Frozen Aftershock
that's not that bad of an idea I could
bracket whip you up something with that
I'm yeah I'm in man Aftershock
anybody but that jager machine
fantastic that was a new age space yeah
uh that was a raven The Raven had one of
those that's where my that's where my
Jaeger my Jaeger consumption really
kicked into high gear I remember
everybody do shots of Jager I'd do shots
of [__] everybody do shots of whiskey I
do shots whiskey man I remember doing uh
Jager Bombs with uh Red Bull and vodka
yeah right
yeah am I crazy no Jager bombs were
Jaeger in Red Bull okay bombs [__]
Jager Bombs I remember doing that with
in a Red Bull and vodka in a Red Bull
and vodka yeah yeah sure I'm dropping in
that
um all right bombs were big at that
there was a there was a free car bombs
big we're big are we dropping are we
pouring because a lot of places didn't
like when you dropped the glass in yeah
give you [__] uh so drop it they also do
you're about to be a problem in 15
minutes yeah
yeah that was yeah no gentlemen are
doing those we were doing dude we would
go out all a night like you have your
beers you're right you're you know
you're drinking your [__] Miller Lite
your Coors Light you're playing big buck
whatever what have you we would do not
[__] around probably about six yeah
six car bombs on a night of [__]
boozing on top of the beers
crazy we were doing them we were
watching the Flyers play off one year
and every time they scored we would do
[__] Jager Bombs or [__] car bomb
it was crazy they were 10 bucks a clip
too making that bacon egg and cheese
about to taste real good oh yeah stop it
Wawa on the way home get a [__] that
was back when they had a broken down
menu now it's all [__] hoarders good
night
um yeah Hmm this one uh but that was
back to that was the shore house I
always said
my aunt's house right so yeah we have a
shore house we have a house in Sea Isle
and it was I didn't even have keys no
and somebody was there all the time were
you allowed to just show up whenever you
want it uh if I could get down there
yeah yeah I would spend a lot of time
down there they would be like what are
you doing here who you're it my name
Patty anytime you showed up totally cool
yeah man I'd say that's
but the problem is I couldn't get there
I didn't have a call like pre-car sure
but I would go stay there when my mom
would be working and you know whatever
needed a break from [__] watching my
fat ass uh yeah I'd go down there with
uh play with the horseshoe crabs yeah
I'd go down there my Aunt Carol Mikey's
mom would take me and Mikey down okay
and hang out for like two three weeks or
whatever my mom will come down on the
weekends or whatever you know he was a
baby yeah yeah good stuff yeah I would
say that's your shore house then or I'd
say
you know we have a Shore House my family
I'd be vague my family has a Shore House
family I know
family I've met one time as it sure
happened
uh all right let's see this is one this
one's from kippy's nippies first time
long time uh do you this all right give
me a second this is a pronunciation one
that I've never thought about
it's do you pronounce it it's
coyote the the animal the coyote sure do
I say coyote no here this one is
yeah I guess would be coyote
coyote
or coyote
coyote I'm I put a d on it that's bad
wow you gotta watch out for the coyotes
coyotes with a D no with a t coyotes
coyotes yeah
the [__] two coyotes came over the
coyotes man this show really brings out
how bad I am at talking
yeah
damn
coyote I said ant
four times last night and every time I
said why the [__]
instead of Aunt ER aunt just comes out
weird aunt aunt and Patty Patty and
Carol that in with when I'm not paying
attention it is wit
sure I watched it with sound awasha was
with with sound I watched it with sound
yeah you say yeah I'm a [__] Dirtbag
yikes I remember one time I was working
in Philly when I was working at Macy's
shout out to the Wannamaker building no
big deal Center City nobody says coyote
though I think like westerners do sure
that would make sense if you live three
coyote yeah
yeah I like coyotes I like wolves not
coyotes are wolves big yeah but they I
feel like they have a little more honor
coyotes are like Savages maybe they
steal your dog come and get your
chickens and [__] I like that so with
the Wolves but sure I feel like they
live by like a mafia code did I ever
tell you the story
we were
he's a friend of ours
it's wolf
that's Tony's brother that's Tony's kid
brother's nephew his grave feet he's a
good friend of ours
you know what I mean am I an [__]
with that yeah you're an [__] but for
other reasons uh fair enough every time
you time we were smoking weed in the
woods and I thought I saw a wolf
panicked
full-blown this is one I was when I was
starting to realize I can't handle weed
I I get pan anxiety it's Panic it's just
a foreign exchange student no it was a
[__] German Shepherd
running right at me dude and I [__]
panicked
or a husky or something hey husky he's a
wolf I had a [__] dog yeah but I
didn't react like it was a husky I
reacted like it was a Huskies I'll get
you [__] pick him with a snowball
cooking at us and I [__] panic and I
everybody ruined the Hang dude
Everybody's scared
a bunch of 12 year olds smoking weed and
the one fat kid starts yelling wolf
can't not believe that you can't roll
the dice and go oh he's these boys
crying Suburban neighborhood in the
middle of summer
goddamn polar bear it was dust dude did
you try to play it off or were you or
were you like that was for sure
[Music]
I ran to my boy Justin's out like ran
like
a half a mile dead Sprint left everybody
high and dry hey we're like Dave finally
made up with me like 10 minutes late
like what the [__] is that
ah my back hurts Jesus it was a goddamn
wolf then uh we were hanging out where
we used to hang out shout out to Village
picture you now sitting around same same
me same me same demeanor same receding
hairline
screaming wolf panic
full-blown panic
yell wolf take off then we're skating
where we used to escape this place
Village shires hold on I think if that
was the case you've lived up to your
obligations you scream over and run yeah
it's every man for himself it's every
High teenager for himself at that point
he shouldn't have been standing there I
don't know what to [__] tell you
you just you just went to go I did my
part I wanted the others
[Laughter]
so then a couple days later we're
skating uh at the you know at the
shopping center we would hang out at the
brown bear showed up
goddamn killer whale you believe that
[__]
giant squid
Portuguese man o war
right there on top of the acne
and we saw I was in the middle of the
kickflip I didn't know where the [__] or
go blind
goddamn pterodactyl over there at the
mall
couple more what do you think
that's still pretty in hey you know what
so am I
is it Tyrannosaurus Rex
oh that was it you went too big I was
going to do giraffes yeah I was going to
do dragon
dragon was in the middle right
um
so then we're hanging out next couple
days we we start seeing him uh King Kong
running straight ahead
starts
guys nobody move
is that python looking at me or am I
crazy
nobody moved
nobody love a girl
all right
[Laughter]
am I crazy or is that lion headed right
for us
what the hair to make it look
no we start seeing signs for like a
missing husky or whatever and I was like
that's the [__] that was the wolf I
saw yeah yeah
you could have found the dog and brought
it back to the person that was days ago
and in my head that was a wolf lady you
shouldn't be having a wolf that's your
problem if he gets out there wild
animals he probably wants to return back
to the goddamn Wilderness [__]
thirsty for blood yeah
that kid blood
trying to have a rack of hoes in me I
would have been a sweet treat for that
Beast
you know when you think something's real
and you realize it's not all the time
all the time man I reacted as if a wolf
was in here that's how that like if if a
wolf walked through right that's how I
properly I [__] freaked out dude
that was the last time I smoked weed
all right
all right let's see let's do uh let's do
one or two more here and then we got our
wrapper out there gang
uh
uh let's see this was from Lukey Duke
um
do you guys ever have
full-blown Crabapple wars did you even
have crabapple trees if not why were
they trees drought they were trees that
dropped hundreds of rock hard bite-sized
apples in the summer and we would get as
gather as many as possible and have
full-on welt wars in the neighborhood
we did yeah yes is that like a Northeast
thing maybe crab apples I don't know we
had us I just figured they were
everywhere until this guy's saying yeah
I think if you waited long enough you
could eat them oh I don't think so no
crab apple Cove that's where Alan Alda
lived on Mash that was his fictitious
Hometown yeah they were like little size
of a plum or something you know what I
mean like a little [__] you up what they
would do and they would hurt yeah you
would [__] beam them but we had a
sickled pear tree in our backyard oh
that's a shame
no insurance either even your fruit has
blood diseases yeah Jesus Christ they're
[__] delicious uh they were similar
to the size of a crab apple but yeah I
guess crabapples never really can you
eat crab apples Toby give that a goose
I'm sure you I don't think they're
poisonous but they probably angry no
I think they would be out yes you can
eat crab apples generally they're too
tart to eat raw but they're
apolline is intense when cooked yeah oh
yeah treat them yeah can't just be raw
dogging them yeah
you get hit with a rotten one of those
you never get that stink off I can taste
that smell oh man it leaves like a it
would leave like a chalk on your fingers
yeah it says it has a really high pectin
content which doesn't sound good I think
it is pectin's good for you
I'm pretty sure good pectin
I've never [__] heard of it no oh
that's good pectin uh pectin is a
heteropolysaccharide nailed that a
structural acid contained in the primary
lamella in the middle of the I don't
know what the [__] any of this means
it's a good fish is it good for you
tough act interacting is it good for you
uh it says it's good for jams and
jellies
okay oh pectin pectin is something that
you put in that to like thicken it up
I think that is what that's true though
okay they put pectin in like two jelly
something
or to it acts like a gelatin you add
pectin to some gelatinous yes
it's a starch that's a shot at me
occurring in produce such as it could be
if you want it to be as it starts
occurring in produce such as apples and
citrus fruits there you go yeah starch
what is this marmalade hour let's go we
gotta wrap it up
gang we love you to death oh yes Family
episode here in the new edition we can't
thank you guys enough Kippy what do you
got for him uh as you guys know we are
all over the gosh darn Road out there
shows are selling out which is [__]
awesome it's so cool to [__] meet
everybody it's [__] fantastic we do
the pickies uh do the meet and greet
it's awesome get tickets to a show near
you we're announcing our second leg
pretty soon got the suits working on it
figuring it all out we're coming to your
city don't stop hitting me up or coming
all right gang gang we love you and
we'll see you next week peace